knock knock who's there oh it's a really
really good episode of Riverdale and
we're breaking it all down on Sweetwater
secrets
hey river babes
I'm your host Leanna Galera and this is
the Sweetwater Secrets after-show for
episode two twenty thirty three shadow
of a doubt which was without a doubt
insane oh my god
it's the black hood now even though this
was an epic episode I'm still dishing
out a long list of things I didn't like
in hisses and kisses plus I'm bringing
an exclusive scoop straight from Lilly
Reinhart talking all about dark Betty
but first we need to discuss the fact
that we have yet another potential death
in Riverdale in the blue and gold
breakdown first up two of the biggest
questions from the musical episode were
finally answered turns out moose was
pissed backstage because he discovered
that mitch was slithering with someone
else on the side things you know guilty
this makes you look the new sheriff in
town
arrested fangs but when no one can prove
if he murdered Mitch it was time to let
him go but here's the problem
Hiram amped up his manipulative ways and
convinced Reggie and the rest of the
dark circle Bulldogs to raise hell for
me
now as Jughead and the rest of the
serpent's tried to protect fangs from
the vicious mob outside the jail Reggie
whipped out a gun now Archie tackled him
to the ground but it looks like it's too
late for fangs meanwhile in black hood
land betty was keeping a suspicious eye
on how while turning to someone new for
help someone who also knows what it's
like to have a murderous father I don't
think he would hurt his own daughter and
I never thought my dad would shoot us
out on the forehead that's right
Betty and Cheryl teamed up this week and
in their quest for answers they were
called to the morgue to check out a body
and apparently it wasn't chick honey
it's okay
but he couldn't fit it looked just like
him I whatever
betting in Sherrill later broke into her
father's share B&B that's clever and
discovered that how had the Nancy Drew
book with the secret code that the black
hood used to send the cipher with now
how pulled some lame excuse I found a
copy online and I was saving it for your
birthday and the Cooper family all
attended the mayoral debate together now
the black hood showed up and started
showering the room with bullets but
what's this how Cooper was down on the
ground while the black hood was firing
up in the rafters what I guess we should
all double down on our Hal has an
identical twin theory or maybe house
working with his other brother Claudius
mmm you tell me now the episode ended
with a very creepy buddy asking her dad
to meet her at town hall so she could
confront him with all her black hood
evidence I wanted to just be between you
and me
now in this episode they dished a lot
about the fact that she has a darkness
in her but don't be too quick to call
her dark Betty
now here's what Lily Reinhart had to
tell me about the distinction between
Betty's internal dark side and the wig
wearing dark Betty we've had a lot more
of dark Betty I'm curious to know what
has been your reaction to how they've
treated dark Betty in season two I feel
like the concept of dark Betty now is a
little just representative of her as a
sexual woman you know like she's coming
into her own and figuring out her
sexuality and I guess you know being a
young woman and you know she's 16 she's
she's exploring she's kind of just lost
her virginity and it's more playful yeah
I don't really think dark Betty is too
much of a representation of her mental
health anymore you know people thought
in season one that's that's what it was
but I think now more so is just kind of
her alter ego in a sexual sin
it's her finding out who she is there
were sexuality as we have an outlet yeah
for sure and on that sultry note let's
jump into seven seconds in heaven now
although we got Tony back this week she
was busy with her serpent duty and
Cheryl was preoccupied with her mission
to help cousin Betty
so things on these Shoni side of things
were rushed straighting li mi a likewise
it was pretty much crickets between
Betty and Jughead
but barchi really stuffed up their game
in this week's episode when Veronica
walked into Archie's room looking oh so
stunning in a black negligee now fans
were treated to barchi kisses
Archie's abs and even some post in work
out cuddles
don't worry Shoni and bug head fans your
end of the season sexy moments are
coming too I'm super excited but for now
let's focus on hisses and kisses now
keep in mind even though I enjoyed this
episode this listed hisses is long and
vicious first up the biggest hiss is
going to the fact that fangs was shot
actually no way no hisses to everything
that happened to fangs in this episode
first off he was dating midge am I crazy
or was Thanksgiving us some serious
flirty eyes too Kevin
earlier this season if he's bisexual
then that's awesome but I'm just so
confused as to why both moose and fangs
to people who clearly appreciate the
male form were romantically linked to
Mitch what am I missing
and then hisses to Reggie for shooting
things outside of the prison I can't
believe that happened
like no I really cannot believe that it
happened because he was on the ground
and then Archie was there and then we
just saw blood and the whole moment just
absolutely infuriated me I'm triggered
we get it this town is dangerous but
stop killing people hisses to Hiram for
not taking his wife's feelings into
consideration and for taking advantage
of Reggie's dim-witted mind and
hot-headed behavior and encouraging them
to wreak havoc on the town get a hobby
Hiram speaking of annoying lodge
behavior hisses to the hole suitors
coming to court Veronica
kind of thing I didn't get it I also
didn't get Veronica's newfound obsession
was starting to casino in town if
anything think about opening up another
restaurant I bet that would do really
well
pisses to the fact that the chick
look-alike in the body bag was not chick
did anyone else rewind to that scene
like 19 times I was so confused it looks
so much like him but then it didn't it
but it's not I don't I don't know this
is too Hal for feeding us that BS excuse
about the Nancy Drew book being a
present for Betty's birthday you're
right but really though when is Bea's
birthday because I'd really like to this
is to Betty for continuing to lie to
Jughead about her involvement with the
black hood did you go to the bus station
I don't know why you keep doing this
girl but I'm getting really tired of it
no God please no on the flip side with
kisses I really did love seeing Betty
confide in Cheryl and watching
Riverdale's cutest cousins team up
together
I love beaten me to pieces but B and C
has a lovely ring to it as well
kisses to Mayor McCoy oh excuse me to
Riverdale Super Lawyer McCoy but could
you please let us know where your
daughter is
yeah okay thanks kisses to see more of
the serpents and Joaquin's brief return
I wonder if he's going to stick around
long enough to say hi to Kevin
no offense Kevin none taken someone love
Kevin kisses to our chief were standing
by his dad for wearing that cute
campaign sweater and to Veronica for
switching sides from teen Hiram to teen
Fred I'm supporting your runs from here
good job girls and kisses to the fact
that we're in the homestretch now guys
just two more episodes left in season
two oh it's almost over check back with
me next week for the Sweetwater secrets
previews show for episode 221 chapter 34
the killing of a sacred deer where I'll
hopefully be able to shed some light on
that truly bizarre title but for now you
guys know the drill River babes give
this video a like and then hit the
comments with your top hisses and kisses
of the episode plus what are your latest
black hood theories does Hal have a twin
is he working with Claudius do you still
care tell me or tweet me
to you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]